many times now I've heard Ai and nft
Bros going on about how AI art is this
Grand democratization of Art and
honestly that drives me insane to listen
to not just because art itself is a
product of human creativity and a
culmination of lived experience but
because it just doesn't make any sense
time and time again history has proven
that if you have a good enough story to
tell a Creative Vision that resonates
with an audience at the end of the day
what your art looks like just doesn't
matter hell both one punch man and MOB
psycho 100 are some of the single most
popular pieces of written media to come
out of Japan and those look like this
talk to just about any other
professional artist and they will tell
you all the same thing I will but any
art you make yourself even if it comes
out a bit wonky looking will be
immensely more meaningful and valuable
than stolen artwork because that's what
art is about creating something
meaningful